So everything that is happening around Trump,
Iran is terrible.
There is the possibility of learning something
from this though. And I want to take this
opportunity because there are lots of people
in my audience who may be too young to remember
the March toward with Iraq in March of 2003
and in 2002 leading up to the eventual invasion
of Iraq in 2003. This was one of the first
big political events in my life. So we had
nine 11 in 2001, uh, that, uh, and I remember
that. And then I remember following and, and
sort of processing what was going on. And
eventually we got to the lead up to and the
eventual invasion of Iraq in 2003 during the
George W. Bush administration, one of the
characteristics of the lead up to the Iraq
war was the propagandizing about imminent
threats from Saddam Hussein. Saddam was linked
to the nine 11 attacks. Of course, that wasn't
true. Uh, the reality at the time we later
found out was that the war in Iraq had already
been agreed upon.
In a sense, it had been pointed to as a target
a decade earlier when George H w Bush didn't
get done what he wanted to get done in Iraq,
and then it was just a matter of manufacturing
enough public consent to go ahead and do it.
And with nine 11 and with Colin Powell and
Condi rice citing bogus intelligence and saying,
we've got to go, it's an imminent threat.
It's time to do it. They were ultimately able
to manufacturer enough consent to go and do
it. We are seeing a very, very similar propaganda
campaign now around Iran with some key differences.
Let's talk about the differences. Number one,
Trump is not George W. Bush without romanticizing
George W. Bush because he was a disaster.
Donald Trump is much more unhinged than Bush
in terms of Bush at least felt the need to
fabricate a bogus case for going into Iraq.
Donald Trump doesn't really seem to feel the
need to do that, and you will see that by
virtue of how thin the justification they're
giving is.
Another important difference between Iran
2020 and Iraq 2003 is that the media today
is not what it was in 2003 Fox news was around
in 2003 I think in 96 Fox news started, but
in 2003 Fox news was not what it is now. The
social media echo chambers that further manufacturer
consent were nothing in 2003 compared to what
they are today. So let's dig into this. The
case that the white house is making for why
it made sense to without authorization from
Congress, which Donald Trump claimed when
Barack Obama was president was necessary for
this type of military action without even
communicating with congressional leaders,
without even communicating with our European
allies. Donald Trump says he urgently had
to go in and assassinate Kaseem Sola Mani
because he was imminently planning attacks
against American forces and diplomats in the
middle East. No evidence has been presented.
So again, difference from 2003 in 2003 they
created all sorts of evidence, much of which
we later found out was incorrect in order
to justify going into Iraq.
Donald Trump is not even presenting any evidence.
What they are saying is it was just imminent,
it was imminent and it all appears to be a
lie to us. Officials briefed about this, say
that the evidence for assassinating Kaseem
Soleimani is quote razor thin. That's diplomatic
speak for. There is no real evidence. We've
just created a speculative case based on some
isolated and irrelevant facts and we know
what those facts are. According to reporter
Rukmini column Maki, the so called evidence
was number one Solomanis pattern of travel.
Number two Solomanis request to visit the
Supreme leader of Iran to get approval for
an operation which could be anything and number
three Solomanis allegedly more belligerent
position towards American interests in Iraq.
This is not evidence of imminent attacks.
This is not a good guy. We don't at any point.
It's important for the left not to feel like
we have to defend Solemani.
He was a bad guy. He did horrible things.
The question is by Trump's own standards of
requiring congressional approval and not being
a bloodthirsty warmonger was this the right
thing to do? The answer is no. We then have
much like with Saddam Hussein in 2002 in 2003
the nine 11 card which has been pulled, vice
president Mike Pence mentioned this, tweeting
that Kaseem Sola Moni quote assisted in the
clandestine travel to Afghanistan of 10 to
12 of 10 of the 12 terrorists who carried
out the September 11 terrorist attacks in
the United States. This is so flacid that
you could just blow and it would fall over
like a piece of paper. Remember that if assisting
in travel is evidence of complicity in nine
11 the U S gave the nine 11 hijackers visas
and allowed them to come to the United States.
It's, it's thin in both cases and it is not
actually evidence of anything.
The nine 11 commission looked at allegations
of Iran's complicity in nine 11 no Arabians
were involved. There were no Arabians in the
Al-Qaida network that carried out the attack.
This is revisionist history and we can't allow
it and I feel like I'm being transported back
almost 20 years to 2002 and the lead up to
the Iraq war. Lastly, and I hate to say lastly
because this actually is a huge deal, there
is still no serious legal basis for this assassination
that has been established. We will certainly
be talking more about the legal basis and
that fiasco later on this week. The consensus
from many foreign policy analysts and simply
from rational people able to think is that
this is exactly what Trump said Obama would
do, but it's Trump who's doing it. Trump tweeted
endlessly years ago that Barack Obama, in
order to help himself get reelected, would
go to war with Iran.
We don't have to look far here. Look at some
of Donald Trump's old tweets quote, in order
to get elected, Barack Obama will start a
war with Iran quote. Now that Obama's poll
numbers are in a tailspin, watch for him to
launch a strike in Libya or Iran. He is desperate
quote. Now that Obama's poll numbers are entails,
spin wa Oh the, I already read that one there.
There are many, many more. Uh, Obama didn't
do it. Trump is impeached. Trump is facing
a tough reelection. It is abundantly clear
that one element here is Trump doing this
to distract from impeachment. And because
he believes it will help him get reelected
in 2020 and I hate to admit this, it's, it's
really, it's disgusting that I, I'd be lying
if I didn't admit it. It actually might work.
If you have seen how quickly most Republican
senators and almost all Trumpists have fallen
in line and said, Hey, listen, this was a
bad guy. Trump is big and strong. He went
and he got him. He's sending the message that
you cannot do this. You cannot attack American
interests or people or assets overseas or
anywhere. They are falling in line. Much like
many of the, we will be greeted as liberator's
crowd fell in line behind the Iraq propaganda
of Colin Powell and Donald Rumsfeld and Dick
Cheney and of course George W. Bush in 2002
in 2003 this might actually work and get Donald
[inaudible]
Trump reelected just 10 months from today.
We're going to keep talking about this, but
in the meantime, let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at D Pacman. The show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show, the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com